die große frage dieses montagmorgens
kammern
sexualstraftäter heilen können
sexualstraftäter nach ihrer klasse zeit
einfach wieder normal unter uns leben
diese fragen stellen sich jetzt aufs
neue im fall eileen was für ein
grausamer fall die 14-jährige aus dem
kleinen dorf gottenheim mit baden
württemberg dort am ende gefunden nach
10 tagen nach denen sie vermisst wurde
in hessen aufgefunden tod opfer offenbar
eines vorbestraften
sexualverbrechers
der trottel sie in hessen ein beliebtes
ausflugsziel für spaziergänger und
anwohner ein ruhiger see mitten in einem
naturschutzgebiet und womöglich der
tatort eines grausamen verbrechens am
freitagnachmittag findet die polizei
hier die leiche der 14-jährigen angehen
300 kilometer entfernt von ihrem zuhause
was ist geschehen wieso musste das
mädchen sterben am donnerstagabend 21
juli wurde die 14-jährige aylin aus
gottenheim bei freiburg vermisst die
eltern schalteten sofort die polizei ein
denn eileen galt als zuverlässig wie die
polizei rekonstruierte gegen eileen wohl
zu einem freund wollte dort ein pullover
bringen um 16 uhr verlässt ein linie
elternhaus im 2000 seelen ort gott nein
der weg zu ihrem freund ist kurz nur 200
meter trennen die beiden voneinander
berlin läuft die hauptstraße entlang
biegt in die bahnhofstraße ein und
klingelt im schul acker an der haustür
ihres freundes doch ihr freund ist nicht
zu hause sein bruder hört das klingeln
aber reagiert zu spät berlin ist weg die
ermittler gehen davon aus dass elin
ihren mörder in freiburg trifft ein
zeuge sieht das braunhaarige mädchen am
selben abend am bahnhof in freiburg dann
verschwindet spurlos
bis zum vergangenen freitag im 300
kilometer entfernten teufelssee finden
die ermittler die leiche des jungen
mädchens ein kleiner see nordöstlich von
frankfurt am main
wurde eileen am teufelssee getötet oder
versucht ihr mörder hier ihre leiche zu
verstecken unklar die arbeit der
rechtsmediziner gestaltet sich als
schwierig ali ins körper trieb zu lange
im warmen see wasser ihr mörder laut
medienberichten soll es sich um einen
bereits verurteilten
sexualstraftäter handeln auf einem
gefängnisaufenthalt wurde der mann von
der polizei beobachtet um das
rückfallrisiko zu senken berlin und dem
mörder sollen chat kontakt gehabt haben
die staatsanwaltschaft und die polizei
freiburg ermitteln unter hochdruck um
antworten auf diesen grausamen mord zu
finden die eltern und ihre sieben
geschwister werden derzeit von einem
seelsorger betreut
[Musik]